hello everyone and welcome to the finals
of the 1971 candidate series it's Bobby
Fischer vs. Tigran Petrosian
it's round five game five that is and
well if you've been with the series so
far then you know that the result so far
is two points each Fischer won the first
game then Petrosyan won the second game
and then Game three which was a really
competitive game was a draw and then
Game four was a really really quick draw
but it was basically a game a repeated
game that was already played in 1969
World Chess Championship match between
Boris Spassky and Tigran Petrosian so
there you have it let's check out Game
five and we do have as I mentioned
already perhaps during Game one or Game
two
that I will receive some photos from the
San Martin theater in Buenos Aires so
here they are there we have it this is
the hole probably where you enter the
theater here we have also a view from
the other direction and here we have the
playing hall so here where you can see
the drum set here where it's really
light there's the place where the table
for the where the board was for the
Fischer petrosyan match there's the
place they were sitting at and the
audience was all around well over the
audience's so there we have it
I do hope you enjoyed this and thank you
very much
to uh such a diligent subscriber for
sending this to me
now let's check out the game so for this
game Game five favorite once again opens
with E 4 we have E 5 and now Knight to
f3 and here for the first time in this
match we have Knight to f6
Petrosyan opts for the petrov defense
here at night characters on e5 but when
he mentioned during the game that's a d4
was giving black much more problems in
you know current tournaments but Fischer
goes for the for the classical line not
for the Steinitz attack Knight captures
on e5 d 6 Knight to f3 and Knight
captures on e4 we have V 4 and here well
if you ever play the classical variation
of the against the petrov then you will
most likely encounter d5 here but here
Petrosyan goes for a different idea he
plays Knight back to F
yes I move with the night back and
botanique mentions that this is like the
world the setup here is basically a
Malayan defense but instead instead of
this night being on d6 that the night is
actually on f6 which only favors black
oh okay but should be three Bishop to e7
and here Fischer wants to play c4 but he
doesn't want to allow Bishop to g4 such
a such a nice development of the bishop
so first he plays h3 h3 now limiting
this bishop and also preparing to
develop this Bishop to f4 while also
creating a nice square on h2 for the
dark square bishop so what unique really
compliments Fisher here he says that
like Young's miss love
Fisher really puts his pieces on optimal
squares we have castles castles c6 by
petrosyan rook to e1 and now Knight B to
d7 Bishop to f4
we have rook to e8 and now c4 okay
Knight to a fate we have Knight to c3
and now comes a six and here Queen to d3
by Queen to b3 by pressure here botanic
says that Queen to b3 isn't the greatest
of moves here he says that a4 is a move
that the definitely should have been
played here preventing any country
planned on the Queen side and also that
this would come very handy later on the
weakening of the be Foursquare is not
all that important because it's very
unlikely that black will be able to use
this be Foursquare for either of his
knights okay a sex Fisher goes Queen to
b3 and now we have nine three six
bushra back to h2 has Fisher already
made a nice retreat Square on h2 and
here
Bishop to f8 a b5 was possible
immediately but as Fischer never tried
to prevent it Petrosyan
doesn't take advantage of it just yet
rook to e2 now Fischer prepares to
double up rocks on the e-file and the
now comes the b5 finally Petrosyan
expands on the Queen side rook a to e 1
here Fischer doubles up rooks and here
we have a rush up the b7 if you try
something like h6 here then you know you
you have to notice that the rooks aren't
really connected and here defy would be
a pretty big threat for example CCAP
and now you capture on b5 captures and
Bishop captures you attack the rock on
e8 and after rock moves and now comes
Knight captures and here you wanna pawn
but that's not really the main issue
here the many the main issue here that a
white would have to connected passed
pawns on the Queen side okay but should
be seven patrols and prevents this and
now Queen the c2 here d5 doesn't really
work all that well now that Bishop to b7
has been played because now after you
capture here now you capture on b5 and
now d4 comes opening up the bishops
diagonal 94 Knight captures Bishop
captures Bishop captures rook captures
pawn captures and after Knight captures
on d4 Knight captures rook captures
Knight captures on b3 rook captures and
EH look after sandy eight and they
capture some b3 you can see that the
material on the board is completely
equal but Fischer would have to doubled
be pawns and Peterson would have an
isolated B and an isolated D pawn so
black would be slightly better here and
a dark square bishop for both of them
so here although seems like a very
active move it's basically a draw
invitation so first pressure goes back
Queen to c2 create some pressure against
the h7 pawn and here g6 by Petrosyan and
here both Hennig mentions that if you
look at Fischer species here and the
pawn structure he has a pawn on c4 and
then d4 that's excellent
the Knights are ideally placed sorry
about that the Queen and Bishop are
creating some nice pressure against the
King side the dark square bishop is a
very nice piece slicing all the way here
and the roofs are nicely doubled on the
e-file so Fisher favorite pieces are
optimally placed but yet as Botvinnik
mentions a tigran's position is
impenetrable something Teagan often does
a bar okay we have before here by favor
B captures on c4 Bishop captures on c4
now creating a triple attack against the
knight and e6 and here Knight the c7
which is a very nice move because this
d5 although it seems like the best move
kick away the bishop and then and win
the pawn for example Bishop d3 Bishop
capture some before now you get rook to
be one and now from that impenetrable
position
white is actually starting to create
some chances here so instead after
Bishop to c4 Petrosyan goes back at
night to c7 and now we have Bishop to b3
here we have a moment where not not just
both me but also Viktor Korchnoi gave us
his suggestion here a question instead
of this move Fischer played as suggested
the route captures on e8
fortunately said that this would at
least remove one of the Knights
defending the d5 square for us so for
example if the knight captures on e8
only then Queen to b3 and with an attack
against the f7 pawn and now after d5
Bishop to d3 this Bishop comes
completely alive so this would be a
pretty big plus for white and now if you
want to you know challenge this bishops
influence on this diagonal then you're
gonna get Bishop to e5 Bishop captures
pawn captures attacking the knight
Knight to d7 and now with a six
it's definitely white who is playing for
the win here so not a bad suggestion by
Viktor Korchnoi you know quite a guy
that that Viktor but okay Fischer played
Bishop to b3 and now we have rook
captures an e2 by Petrosyan rook
captures night C to d5 botany describes
this night cd5 move as pure art because
now you can see that petrosyan spawns
really do control the center here and if
any exchanges are made here on the
center it will only favor black and now
also this move comes with a tempo it
attacks the b4 pawn so now again
Botvinnik says that in that position if
you remember in the opening an a4 would
have been a better move and now moves
like b5 would have been possible and so
on and so on but okay we have a three in
defending now comes a five pressuring
the b4 pawn and now Knight captures on
d5 seek after son d5 now comes b5 by
Fischer and a4 by petrosyan Bishop to a
two-button excess that capturing here
probably would have been better Queen to
a5 with a double attack on the bishop
then after Bishop moves Queen comes to
h3
with a pawn capture but saying that this
would have been better for white but
okay
pressure goes Bishop 282 immediately we
have Queen to b6 and now Queen to be one
rook to a5 piling up against the b5 pawn
rook to b2 and the now comes Knight to
e4 a move that botany describes as
petrosyan you know patrol sense
advantage slipping away here botanist
suggests Bishop to h6 as a much more
active idea but also the Bishop to c8
idea is very nice simply preparing to
introduce another attacker against the
b5 pawn of course first you're gonna go
back up to f5 for example favourable to
play something like bishop to afford to
prevent butter up to h6 then comes the
Bishop to f5 attacking the Queen Queen
moves and now bush will be back to d7
with a triple attack against the b5 pawn
Bishop to g5 rook captures on b5 rook
captures Bishop captures with an attack
on the Queen Queen b1 pinning the bishop
and then out comes Knight to e4 with an
attack on this Bishop and here you would
have a position where black has six
months and the Fischer only has five
points and it's a very promising
position for black but you know probably
petrosyan as usual was was very long
time and it's only moved 27 so not not
even close to time control so first
Petrosyan goes Knight to e4 immediately
and here Fischer does have some chances
of equalizing rather easily
Bishop to f4 was played nice to see
three now with an attack against the
Queen and the bishop and here we have
Queen to c2 rook captures on b5 by
petrosyan capturing the bishop here
would have been a bit tricky because
after rook captures Queen captures Queen
to c7 is a possibility and again it
would be it would be probably white
would be looking for chances in this
game so as he doesn't enjoy this we have
rook captures and now route captors on
b5
nightcap for some b5 and now Queen
captures on a four official only
eliminates d4 pawn and creates a passed
a three point but it will it will not be
a very useful pass pawn queen to a6
offering a queen trade we have Queen
captures the Bishop captures and now
comes Bishop to e3
there's really no wait
to keep an eye on the a3 point really no
way of actually protecting it if you
push it then simply night with the tacit
with an attack against the bishop and
the pawn and wouldn't really work so
Bishop to e3 further giving further
protection to d3 pawn we have Knight
captures and now Bishop captures on d5
Bishop to c4 with push up to c6 and now
Knight the c2 attacking the bishop
bishop - d - we have Bishop to e2 now
attacking the knight the bishop to e4
bushra captures Bishop captures on c2
and here after Bishop to d5 was played
here the players agreed to a draw as the
position is added draw completely equal
three points on the Kings side three
pawns on Kings at each one isolated pawn
in the center of the board and two
bishops each completely drawn so a very
you know eventful game 5 to say the
least
and again we had I mean Fischer played
excellent chess but the defense
Petrosyan presented was even more
impressive if you know probably if not
for time trouble it would be patrolling
who would be pushing for something more
than a draw in this game but it's game 5
you know two and a half points each and
we are then now coming into game 6
the thing with Game six is that I
already did a video on Game six some
more than a year ago so I will be
remaking a video of Game six but I'm not
sure if I will be able to do it today so
for those of you who you know can't wait
they want to see what happens in Game
six and are eager to see how this story
continues you the first thing you will
see in the description below will be the
game at 6 I already made a year ago so
also it could be a nice opportunity for
you to see how this channel developed
how this you know to perhaps follow the
evolution of the channel see how I
created my videos like a year ago and
how I do it now so feel free to check it
out and for those of you who would
rather wait for a remake I will probably
probably do it today but if not tomorrow
definitely so I would like to thank
Justin angel still Steph and Dottie
mr. KH rbl Garcia and
Michael steppin for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot - really
appreciate it
as usual you can check - on my previous
videos here think all for watching and
I'll see you soon
with wood game sex definitely of this
epic match so thank you all and see you
soon and enjoy the rest of your Friday